[Music]
so shark tank luck people don't
understand is a really grueling tough
long day and you got to be sharp cause
you're basically buying and selling
millions of dollars with a product so
that means you can't go there with a
hangover believe me I've done that
before it's bad investments hungover on
shark tank so it's a different kind of
lifestyle you're gonna eat late be
lightly obviously maybe have one glass
of wine then go to bed sleep for five or
six hours get up work out and then get
to the set on time we're about seven in
the morning here we'll have to set
around 7:30 then we got to hit make up
got it this is the first day of shooting
so it's gonna be chaos we gotta get the
lighting checks done and we'll do some
of the promo stuff then we'll do what
are called beauty shots all this stuff
is gonna happen before we see the first
contestant which probably won't happen
till about 9:00 or so but people don't
understand which we'll see today so
they're behind the scenes shark tank
deals can run for like an hour in 20
minutes and they get cut down to seven
but that means you know technically we
could spend twelve hours shooting one
show that's only 44 minutes long at the
end of the day and what I like to say to
everybody about shark tank it only takes
one ID
it only takes one idea to set you free
you get a good idea you get funding on
Shark Tank millions of people see it you
sell millions of dollars of the product
you're such a family free that's why we
do this it's great to support
entrepreneurs it's wonderful for the
investor in these deals fascinating it's
just every year it's different it's just
never know what's gonna come down the
pike I guarantee you the deals when you
see today are like unlike any other
we've seen for the last ten years
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Chris Brown decided on the same exact
day that mine come up because I hate it
when guys do that really so do you get
any advance notice about what's coming
down the pike or is it total surprise
spontaneous on-the-spot never know I
mean there's a there's a law that wasn't
put in place in the 60s called the game
show law when when game shows are rigged
and somehow that's permeated itself into
the dose of shark tank to so we're not
allowed to know or even have met these
people beforehand they have to sign
something that says they've never met us
and I think that's the right thing to do
because we're going through the
exploration of what the company is all
about and we're doing it together with
the viewer and I think that's what makes
shark tank so finale I don't know
anything about them when they walk in
but I'll tell you something over the
years I feel the Karma I know before
they even say a word but I'm gonna do
deal with them or not it's just that
more that's happening on the carpet I
look them in the eye
they look back at me I mean it must be
really scary for them the lights are
shining on them I mean you know they've
been practicing but when you actually
get out there the 26 cameras are rolling
there's 100 producers in the background
the Sharks are lit up there and you got
a pitch that's when the metal really
starts to show that's when the rubber
hits the road and I know right away can
they handle it or not I've seen people
just pass out even I've seen everything
that shark attack you can't
some people break out in tears I think
that you got it you can't fry come on do
you think it's stuff in the shark tank
little the real world gets ahold it will
eat you alive but it's a test it's a
journey you know it's part of your
journey and if you do well on there
knows what can happen that's okay
everybody welcome into the dark
cavernous shark tank soundstage whoo I'm
on the shark tank set to feed the cash
to crew this morning we'll have a little
steak and eggs
[Music]
chef's wonderful here and I've got big
news you know my fantastic sous-vide
which means under pressure I am making
the most amazing sirloin tip roast for
the holidays two point seven pounds 16
servings sent to you already prepared in
my special Suvi method hi Matthew
yes this is Sean may I try to feed a
shuttle and this is a tenderloin 32.7
our roast oh my god did you make yes I
did
what does subete mean it means I take
the meat shrink wrap it vacuum seal it
and cook it in a hundred and forty-one
degrees for just the right time to make
it perfectly medium-rare throughout that
laughs and taste is amazing
then I flash freeze it and ship it to
you it's no fuss no muss ready to go
ready
that's wait till a cast and crew chase
dish oh my goodness what a perfect way
to have breakfast that is what I'm
talking about
a beautiful piece of tenderloin
perfectly cooked
Gammage like to try something
[Music]
Kevin you have to stop try what do you
do you try that try that that's my sous
beep three-point tenderloin how's that I
thought you went in ear first
this is amazing it is amazing it's
perfect I'm a cast and crew we're having
steak and XS morning isn't that
fantastical you simply put it in the
fridge overnight let it thaw out like I
have done and then cut this beautiful
piece of meat which you're gonna see in
a minute it is delish you're so
magnificent it is just spectacular now
look I'm very proud of this if you're
looking for a roast for the holiday
chef's wonderful is your man I beautiful
let me repeat two point seven pounds 16
servings perfectly cooked
each you what rumba let's go take it out
and cut it up steak and eggs in the
morning on the shark tank set absolutely
fantastic and you know what this is
going to be a monster hit when I bring
it to the market because it's so good
you can't believe this even if it is so
amazing cooking me exactly her 41
degrees sealed in water is birth you
don't have to risk drying out the
outside and have an inside block
that's why subete that's the secret of
all the chefs in France that's what they
do they use the sous-vide method which
means under pressure that's what it
means
subete meats under pressure so that's
how you cook now look at how perfectly
cooking
absolutely perfect
gorgeous can you cook a roast like that
it's so hard to do it's the same
temperature throughout isn't that
beautiful
and how does it taste oh my goodness are
you ready
Ronnie get some of that before your ride
what TMJ told Brielle it's just gorgeous
no no dig in dig is how I love to eat
please you must I'm not
you can't believe how tell me how
amazing it is Lizzie you're so tender
throughout yeah it's just gorgeous
come on ladies don't sit this in the
back you want to try it a little protein
in the morning chef wonderful is doing
it right here
yeah baby do you want to try I don't see
a lot of vegans around here really so
are you in or out
don't be a greedy Pig oh I just love the
smell of a good royalty deal in the
morning
[Music]
[Music]